>> Laura: SOME ARE SAYING THE
BEST-SELLING AUTHOR ANN COULTER.
HERE TO RESPOND IS ANN COULTER.
I KNOW YOU DON'T WATCH THIS
OF THESE SHOWS.
WHAT GOES THROUGH YOUR MIND WHEN
YOU SEE THIS, JUST HAD TO
JETTISON ITS BIG ANCHOR AFTER
ALL THE STORIES CAME OUT ABOUT
HIM AND WOMEN AND NOW THIS
STORY LINE?
>> I HEARD ABOUT IT WHEN I GOT
INCOME OF FANS WERE MOSTLY
UPSET, THEY THOUGHT THE ACTRESS
DIDN'T DO ME JUSTICE, GOD BLESS
MY FANS.
THERE WERE THREE DIRECT QUOTES
FROM ME OR AT LEAST LIES ABOUT
THINGS THAT I HAD SAID.
IT WAS PRETTY CLEARLY SUPPOSED
TO BE ME, I DON'T CARE, I COULD
NOT CARE LESS.
I KNOW IT WOULD BE MUCH BETTER
TV IF I DID CARE AND I WAS
INDIGNANT BUT IT COULD BE A
PERSONAL ASSAULT IF AN COULTER
THE PLACE DOWN.
IN FACT, I DID NOT BREAK A
THERE ARE TWO THINGS, I JUST
HEARD THAT SEGMENT BUT IT'S
FUNNY HOW LIBERALS THINK WE ARE
I GATHER WAS SUPPOSED TO BE ME,
THAT'S HOW LIBERALS TALK.
THEY ARE CONSTANTLY IN A STATE
OF OUTRAGE.
COME TO ONE OF MY SPEECHES YOU
WILL SEE THAT'S NOT MY APPROACH.
>> Laura: IMAGINE THERE WAS A
STORY LINE ABOUT POLITICALLY
CORRECT FIGURE BEING RAPED
BRUTALLY.
CONNECTED TO A MUSLIM
I THINK IT WOULD CREATE A HUGE
CONVERSATION.
ISLAMAPHOBIC, HOW DARE YOU BRING
THIS UP.
THIS IS MAKING MY LIFE MORE
DANGEROUS.
>> RIGHT, SERIOUSLY.
MAKE GIVING A SPEECH, THE MAIN
IMPORT OF WHICH WAS GOING TO BE
FEDERAL LAW, WE SHOULD ENFORCE
IT.
THAT WAS ENOUGH TO THREATEN TO
BURN THE CAMPUS DOWN.
PEOPLE ARE BEING THROWN OFF
TWITTER.
I THINK MILO WAS THROWN OFF
TWITTER FOR CALLING AND ACTRESS
UGLY.
I'M THINKING, WHY DON'T THEY
FOLLOW MY APPROACH AND NOT CARE?
I DO THINK IT'S WORTH BRINGING
UP AT THIS POINT RAGING FRAUDS
AND HYPOCRITES, ONE OF THE
THINGS WAS THAT THIS CHARACTER
WANTS TO DEPORT DREAMERS.
I PROMISE YOU THE WRITERS, THE
ACTORS, THE PRODUCERS OF THIS TV
SHOW, WILL MOVE HEAVEN AND EARTH
TO MAKE SURE THEIR KIDS DON'T GO
TO SCHOOL ANY PLACE NEAR A
DREAMER.
THEIR ONLY CONTACT WITH ILLEGAL
ALIENS IS THE WOMAN WHO CLEANS
THEIR TOILET WHOSE NAME THEY
DON'T KNOW.
BUT THEY ARE GOING TO STAND UP
SO MUCH OF HOLLYWOOD IS WANTING
TO FEEL MORALLY SUPERIOR TO
CONSERVATIVES AND PARTICULARLY
TO TRUMP VOTERS.
SO GOOD TO READ AND NOT WATCH
CERTAIN SHOWS ON TELEVISION.